[Music]
so today we have another reverse
cancellation
the cancelers will become the canceled
and as we get
into the story if there's any sincere
person left in america who still
thinks that cancel culture is a myth
doesn't exist
they may want to pay attention and
seriously consider the case of kara
dumaplin
she's a popular baby sleep training
expert who you know i hadn't heard of
before this but
apparently very popular and she has been
ruthlessly attacked boycotted doxxed
and smeared over the past week after
someone will have more on that someone
in a moment
went through fec records and discovered
that she donated to donald trump they
went through the records and found this
out
now many media outlets have reported on
the story eager to amplify the news of a
non-political person's private campaign
contributions and most of the coverage
has been along the lines of this
headline from the
cut which is a new york magazine
publication they say quote a boycott is
brewing against formerly beloved child
care consultant kara dumaplin
who has reportedly been funneling some
of the profits from her pricey classes
into the trump campaign's coffers
now this is disgraceful of course and
also not true
not only are they straining to make
donations sound sinister by using a
phrase like
funneling the profits but they assume
that the money
that's it was being given to the trump
campaign came from her child care
consultant business
but we have no way of knowing that we
don't know where the money came from
she has a husband apparently who works
he's a doctor going to come from him
and it doesn't matter anyway cara
dumaplin
offers advice on how to care for infants
very good advice i have been
told she she never chose to publicize
her personal views
the small amount of money she donated to
a political campaign about a thousand
dollars
a thousand dollars over the course of
three years which is what she said in a
statement to the today show
that's of no one's concern but her own
this is not a case of a public person
choosing to air their political views
and then experiencing the divided
response that any sane person must
expect at this point
this is rather a woman in a completely
apolitical line of work
whose financial records along with her
address have been dug up and published
in order to personally destroy her
in an act of collective ideological
vengeance
it's cancelled culture that's what
canceled culture is hit pieces in the
media claim that moms across america
have somehow been
betrayed they feel betrayed because a
woman who gave them advice on how to
help their infants sleep happens to hold
political views that don't align with
their own
sophia tesfay in salon
she wrote an article openly admitting
that this is another case of cancel
culture but she says that it's good
it's a good thing because it holds
dumaplin accountable for the sin of
possessing a mind and forming opinions
of her own
by the way if you're wondering if you're
not familiar with this woman and you're
wondering what sort of content
this right-wing extremist was putting
out there um here
just as a quick example give you a frame
of reference
uh this this this this dangerous person
who has to be held accountable this
right-wing extremist
here she is this is a sort of typical
content that she would put out here she
is explaining how to properly burp a
newborn this this is the woman
that is right now the target of of
public rage let's let's listen
lots of times i see parents when they
try to burp they put her right
here like this and they do this and
they're trying to burp but she's just
not burping
so here's what i want to show you take
her and put her little chest
up and over your shoulder like this and
then cup your hand make a c like this
you want to hear it hear that that
doesn't hurt her but hear how you can
hear that noise that's what's going to
get your burp out
sometimes parents do this and it just
doesn't get up her about you want to cup
it so it doesn't hurt her back and just
go like this
so that's one method is up over the
shoulder again get her chest
up and over your shoulder like that
wow what an extremist
good advice on the burping though by the
way my favorite method though is you sit
the baby up i think she gets into this
you sit the baby up and hold them sort
of by the chin and then pat them on the
back i think it gets the burp out a
little bit better but anyway
that's what uh that's the kind of that's
it that's that's what she does she just
tells you how to care for babies
um i i'm not aware of any video that
she's ever put out
advocating for a candidate or anything
like that
now the guy who seems to have gotten the
cancel ball rolling in this case
uh his name is jamie grayson and he's a
fellow parenting influencer on instagram
and he quite clearly saw this as an
opportunity to kneecap his instagram
competition he he's the one who first
published or he's one of the original
ones who first published dumaclin's fec
records
which include her address again along
with a lengthy screed promising that
he's a quote very liberal homosexual
male
he doesn't hold any of her heretical
views not me i'm not
i'm not like her and other vultures from
the mommy and daddy
blogger sphere swooped in to get a piece
of the carcass and that's that's how
this all started
this is one of the the primary hallmarks
of cancel culture and it's how you diff
differentiate it from your average
boycott or a genuine case of holding
somebody accountable
the people who are looking to obscure
this issue that's what they'll always
try to equate these things with
and they say well you know it's just a
regular boycott it's holding someone
accountable
now this is how you tell the difference
because in cancel culture it's always
vindictive
and contemptuous and often the bus is
being driven by someone who stands to
personally gain from the destruction of
the person
who's being thrown under it now that's
not to say that the average member of
the outrage mob
you know the moms claiming to be
betrayed and vowing never to use this
child care program again
have self-serving motivations i don't
think they do they're more like maniacs
driven to the edge of insanity by
hatred for their fellow americans and by
their fear of people who think
differently from themselves
just consider for a moment what they're
actually doing here i'm talking about
the average person and i was going
through some of the comments
uh and it was a dark and twisted journey
reading some of the comments of of
former fans of this woman who now say oh
i'm done i can't i'm not going to
use the program anymore assuming they
follow through
on their boycott threats think about
what they're doing
because dumablin by all accounts is a
miracle worker
in the field of baby sleep training
that's her expertise
um over the last day i've spoken to a
number of people who swear by her
methods
say it's a lifesaver and anyone who's
had an infant who struggles to sleep
knows that it can just about wreck your
life at least for as long as the
nighttime struggle sessions continue
we have been through this with a few of
our kids it is it is
very very difficult because it turns out
that sleep is a rather crucial human
need
when you're being deprived of it you
become desperate pretty quickly
there's a reason that sleep deprivation
is considered a form of torture
according to the geneva convention
whether infants are therefore guilty of
human rights abuses as a legal question
for another time but
what all this means is that these
betrayed mothers
will choose now to suffer with a
sleepless baby
rather than use the methods and the
advice of a woman who donated to donald
trump
they are choosing ideology over their
own health and sanity
and they don't have much of the latter
despair to begin with
it makes you wonder whether these people
would intentionally die of thirst if a
trump supporter recommended they drink
water
as this episode shows cancel culture
itself is not
the underlying problem it's real but
it's not
the problem it's not the problem it is a
symptom
the disease is a world view that cannot
tolerate
any form of dissent from anyone it sees
all things in a political light it sees
all people as political entities
it sees anyone outside of its tribe as
an enemy worthy of condemnation and
worse
it clamors for diversity but seeks a
world of sameness
it demands tolerance but never returns
the favor cancel culture
emerges inevitably from this
hateful ideology otherwise known as
leftism
and as we have seen no one not even this
woman is exempt from its wrath
and that's why the cancellers are
canceled and by the way quick pitch for
her
unpaid if you're looking for advice on
how to get a baby to sleep
maybe this is a woman you should support
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content